welcome back to CBS this morning I'm
Anthony Mason with Gayle King and Tony
Tecopa we're learning new details about
Prince Harry and Megan markle's split
from the royal family they'll formally
step down as senior Royals march 31st
and there's controversy surrounding the
couple's attempt to rebrand themselves
following their unprecedented decision
to move on and relocate to Canada
Charlie d'Agata is outside Buckingham
Palace Charlie are we likely to see them
back in Britain anytime soon yes Anthony
there are actually a number of royal
engagements scheduled for next month but
after that it's over and they'll be
closing down their offices here at
Buckingham Palace when Prince Aryan is
then pregnant wife Megan attended last
year's Commonwealth Day church service
in the splendor of Westminster Abbey
they'd only recently begun life as a
working royal couple when they returned
in March of this year it will be one of
their last days on the job from April
1st they're no longer beholden to carry
out duties on behalf of their former
employer Queen Elizabeth and her royal
family nicknamed the firm palace sources
tell us that while Harry will retain his
military ranks his honorary command
positions will be at least temporarily
suspended now when it comes to retaining
the his and her Royal Highness titles it
starts to get murky the couple can keep
them but not use them
we sought clarification from The Sunday
Times royal correspondent Roy Anika
it means Harry Megan Estelle His Royal
Highness and Herald highness but they
won't be able to use those titles when
it comes to striking commercial deals
and it's the use of the word royal in
Harry and Megan's social media that's
currently being reviewed by Buckingham
Palace the couple applied to trademark
the Sussex royal brand in June last year
but it seems they may have done so
without running it past the Queen PR
guru mark Borkowski says the Queen is
deeply protective of that royal brand
and with good reason
it's a major hurdle that's being put in
front of them because clearly the royal
family see them as a threat so they've
got to rethink again about what their
corporate brand stands for now there is
one important caveat to mention here the
palace says this whole transition period
will be reviewed in 12 months which may
leave the door open in case the couple
decides to change their minds Tony
Charlie d'Agata for us in London Charlie
thank you very much I don't know why you
can have the titles but can't use them
doesn't make sense no I'm very confused
there's a lot to sort out there